قال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود تتشوش
اوغلو انه تناول خلال الاجتماع مع وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد الوهايان
الموضوع السوريه بشكل موسع واشاره الى
امكانيه عقد اجتماع ثلاثي على مستوى وزراء
خليجيه تركيا وروسيا وسوريا في الفتره
القادمه
سوريا
وايران تقدمان دعمهما الكبيره لتحقيق هذه
الامور الهامه ومن اجل ضمان ذلك تم
التنسيق الاجتماعي مع نظام السوري لتسهيل
روسيا حيث نظم اجتماعه ثلاثي على مستوى
اجراء الدفاع ومديريه المخابرات في روسيا
ونحن نخطط في الفتره القادمه لاجتماع
ثلاثي المشابهن على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
بعد هذه الاجتماعات ابلغنا ايران
بالتطورات كما ان روسيا اعطتها ما لديها
من معلومات في ما يتعلق بهذه الاجتماعات
همم من جهاته قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
حسين امير عبد الله يعني ان طهران تثمن
تطور العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق مؤكد ان
بلاده تؤمن بان هذه التطورات ستصب في
مصلحه المنطقه
بتعرف
انت غيمه نحن في حاله استشاره دائمه
ومستمره مع تركيا فيما يتعلق بالمواضيع
الاقليميه وسعداء لتطور العلاقات بين
انقره ودمشق وحصول هذه التطورات الاخيره
بينهما نتيجه مساء طويله لبلادنا ايران
مؤمنه بان هذه التطورات ستكون لصالح
منطقتنا كما ان بلادنا ترغب في القيام بما
يجب القيام به لتسريع الوصول الى علاقات
افضل بين الدولتين